So we just calculated the allelic frequencies up
here for the dominant recessive alleles, but what
about the trait itself? How frequent is the
trait of lactose intolerance in our population? Well,
about their homozygous dominant and our heterozygous condition,
they're going to be lactase persistent. And our homozygous
recessive condition is going to be lactase non-persistent. This
is the group that's going to be lactose intolerant.
So, if we calculate the frequency of lactase persistence in my
population, and we've got 500 plus 350 is 850 total people out
of 1,000. That's 0.85. Well, look at that! The frequency of the
dominant allele is 0.675. The frequency of the dominant trait is 0.85.
They're not the same. This is really
important, the allelic frequency and the trait frequency
don't have to match. Take this given
scenario right here. We have a population of
1000 people, remember that means we have
2000 alleles total. And when we calculate our
allelic frequency, we find that the dominant
allele for lactase persistence is prevalent at a
0.75 frequency. The recessive allele is prevalent at at 0.25 frequency.
When we look at the actual trait frequency, lactase
persistence comes in at 1.0, 100%. But lactatse
nonpersistent. The tray to lactose intolerance is 0,
0%. Now, if these things are true, then I want you to enter a possible number
of people for each genotype here. Remember, you have
100 people to choose from, so whatever your numbers you
put in these boxes, it should add up to a
1000. Based on the allelic and the trait frequencies that
you see here, I want you to enter in any
possible number of people that could be each genotype. Go
ahead, give it a try. If you get stuck, try
checking out the forums to see if anyone has some
helpful advice.